ce travail et je veux dire une chose
pour moi mr un truc qu'on doive frappé
c'est qu'on n'a pas la même mémoire on a
la même histoire
[Musique]
ben ali
les primes quand elle gagne à
être grassement la raconter tirailleurs
au cinéma c'est
permettre que cette histoire de deux
passé historique douloureux et peut
raconter soit exhumé un peu pour
participer à un décalage des regards il
ya quelque chose de alors c'est pas de
la réparation le contraire de juste de
reconnaître en fait qu on a une histoire
commune et qu'on peut pas faire marche
arrière donc il faut la regarder il faut
l'enseigner et à partir de là il ya
peut-être quelque chose d'autre qui est
possible
je peux très important d'être là ce soir
de présenter le film pour la première
fois en public ici ce soit à merci à
tous les gens présents ça c'est que vous
allez être dans mes souvenirs les plus
forts
je regardais ce moment là très longtemps
dans ma mémoire merci pour ça et voilà
sur les justes qui offre une chose pour
moi me frustre un truc qu'on doit se
rappeler ce qu'on n'a pas la même
mémoire mon à la même histoire